das ist purer slapstick on ice die
aufnahmen einer überwachungskamera aus
kiew zeigen wie die bewohner auf einer
abschüssigen spiegelglatt vereisten
straße mit den ukrainischen
wetterbedingungen kämpfen
während diese beiden jungen männer
ziemlich cool die straße runter sliden
hat der mann schon etwas mehr für die
große herausforderung zeigt sich aber
als dieser teenager am unteren bildrand
erscheint als er versucht die völlig
vereiste straße hoch zu gehen wird die
szene zur besten comedy nummer slapstick
pur
arbeitet teenager gibt nicht auf
vielleicht klappt es ja auf allen 4
[Musik]
nach gut zwei minuten wird der versuch
schließlich abgebrochen wie heißt es so
schön wer den schaden hat muss für den
sport nicht sagen aber spaß beiseite
wegen des blitzeises ist es am
donnerstag in der ukrainischen
hauptstadt zu mehr als 100 unfällen
gekommen
über 4.000 mitarbeiter der stadt waren
im einsatz um die straßen vom eis zu
befreien
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren